hello we come in peace
and Drax seriously dude Hello friends my
name is Naz Perez and I am sitting next
to the coolest director and cast of
Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3 a film
that has been 10 years in the making
you know I remember when the first
trailer came out people were somewhat
skeptical no one knew walking into the
theater for the first movie that we'd
all be crying over a dead tree and like
fall in love with a raccoon and a guy
that listens to cassette like I feel
like gen Z knows what cassettes are
because of Guardians and really I think
it's a testament to you James I mean to
me you are the king of the Island of
Misfit Toys and it is because of your
virtuosity that we all see ourselves in
the Guardians and I feel like they're
the emotional Touchstone of the MCU so I
wanted to start off by asking you what
is the emotional undertone of this film
you know if volume one was about finding
family and volume 2 is about you know
your chosen family over the one you're
born into what is volume three about
well I think that's true but I also I
really think of I think of volume one as
being about the mother volume two is
about the father and volume three is
about the self and coming to terms with
each of those situations and the first
one Peter Quill is coming to terms with
his relationship with his mother which
is the person you love the most in the
world in volume 2 he's coming to terms
with his relationship with his father
the one he thought he wanted wasn't the
one he wanted and the one he had was
better than what he thought he was and
then in the third one it's about getting
to accept yourself who are we really and
how are we okay you know mantis even
says is it one time in the in the movie
most of them don't like themselves very
much they all have issues with
themselves nebula has issues with
herself Peter Quill has issues with
himself mantis they craglin they all do
and um and and Rocket most of all
so I think that that's what this this
movie is about above and beyond anything
else wow I love it the self and I've
read that you've said that this film is
like more serious or has like a
heaviness to it and I wondered how that
translated to the heartbeat of all these
movies which is the music you know like
what Adele song no I'm just kidding
Peter gets a Zune at the end of
Guardians too you know what type of
music can we expect in this film and is
there a standout song that we should
look out for well I think that you know
that the song that we used in the
trailer that we did only for San Diego
Comic-Con was Do You Realize by The
Flaming Lips and I think that's sort of
Spacey Melancholy Beauty
and love is really what you know
encapsulates a lot of the music and so
it was a big challenge coming into this
movie because we were restricted in
restrictions sometimes help you in the
first two movies to songs that were from
Meredith Quill's time and in this movie
it's the songs off the Zune that yondu
gave to Peter Quill and it's 300 songs
and they're from you know various
different eras and so it's about being
able to find a commonality in songs you
know that are as diverse as you know a
rainbow song and Flaming Lips and
spacehog so it's uh it's I think that
the soundtrack might be people seem to
think it's the best soundtrack I I don't
I have a hard time seeing things like
that objectively but it works really
well and it's the most songs it's 17
songs can you tell us what eras well
it's it's 70s 80s 90s basically 90s
music yeah yeah it's a lot of 90s music
it's predominant early 90s music and is
there a standout song it would be that
flaming lip song I mean I think The
Flaming Lips song there's a couple of
others and the opening song is pretty
amazing too I'm not gonna say what it is
yeah actually makes me cry each time
that song is yeah the core of it all
yeah oh you can't know what it is now
not yet okay it's amazing because also
the songs are written in the script yeah
so that's pretty special and also you
gave us you know a mixtape that we could
like listen to I do yeah I still listen
to it now like when I drive and I listen
to the song that really reminds me of
like when we're shooting this and this
and it's like the it's the emotional
connection that you have with with your
movies you know it's like all the music
and yeah I love that you brought that up
because what's so fascinating and why we
all love James Gunn is because a lot of
the songs are chosen beforehand and
they're done by the time the script is
done and you guys film to music so I
wanted to know from chicory palm and
Sean what was it like filming the music
and was there a moment where you felt
like the music really impacted your
performance in this movie or just made
you feel like so cool definitely for me
I mean
one of the the first thing I I read
before after James uh finally sent me
the script after he offered me the role
was the first time you see the high
evolutionary and he's listening to can I
say that he's listening what he's
listening to is that safe am I allowed
to
so he's listening to um this is so cool
described as a Space Opera right yeah
and for James that's him you know giving
a hint to the cat for me that was the
core of my character in many ways
because I then went out if you remember
when Vancouver I went on and I just got
a list of my favorite quote-unquote
Opera classical music that I felt Define
this guy's life and I would listen to it
hours upon hours and James actually
ended up picking one of the things I
sent him so for me that was the
character there was a grandiosity but
also there was a deep yearning to that
piece that we chose I don't want to tell
you what it is it's worth waiting for
because again it's a sound we associate
with your movies no you know at all that
was like oh this is this is the guy and
out of it spurns so many ideas for me
and then there was another moment with
the scene with Peter Quill when we first
meet actually it's in the trailer when I
tell him don't oh yeah give me a second
that was just magic for me you know
because there are times when things that
aren't logically logical but are very
visceral or ephemeral makes sense to you
in a logical way and for me those were
the moments I was like okay I get where
this guy's at right now you know oh yeah
now I remember also like of course there
was like sometimes like emotional songs
and sometimes there was like songs that
give you power and that yeah make you
feel empowered or you know that it's
gonna be a shot where you when you walk
it's gonna be slow motion and there's
like a cool music on top of it
yes let's go always like you're like
walking like a rock star you know that's
how I feel playing the Lizzie McGuire
soundtrack
same exactly I copied it completely this
is what dreams are made of what about
you Sean yeah we uh you know we have all
the songs beforehand and it's nice to be
able to listen to a song either before
we shoot a scene or if sometimes while
we're shooting the scene and know that
it's almost like a filter on the on the
scene a little bit that you have some
some sense of what the tone of the scene
is already as you go in it's really
really helpful and I think that the I
think if one stuck out more than any
it's the opening credits
um song again which for every movie I
feel that way for all three movies the
opening credits song like injects
something into the ride we're about to
go on I love that you say that because I
feel like if I were to close my eyes and
someone just said Guardians of the
Galaxy the image that pops up in my head
is Star-Lord dancing to come and get
your love like that to me is Guardians
of the Galaxy and I know James that you
did a lot of different screen tests for
Star-Lord before you found Chris and
within a minute of Chris's office I'd
like to say settled Chris
he's not here so that's not that's okay
it'd be more fun if he was and within a
minute you knew that he was Star-Lord do
you remember that day and the day that
you met Zoe and and how have they both
been significant to you as a filmmaker
in these movies they're my friends and
they're my um you know my partners and
uh Chris was from the beginning he's
just so much a part of the heart of this
film his sort of good-natured nice
guyness which is permeates the set when
he's on it and helps to affect
everything and I knew from the beginning
that you know I had written this
character in The Script I wanted it to
be somebody who stood outside of that
character if that makes any sense I want
somebody to come in and be the lines but
really Express you know he's a main it's
not like mantis like when when uh when
Palm auditioned for mantis mantis is
like so specific in the script like
she's such a unique and interesting
character whereas Peter Quill's the
leading man it's like you once somebody
that can bring character to a leading
man and it was very difficult
and when when Chris came in and he
started auditioning for that role
literally you say under a minute it was
definitely it was probably you know 20
seconds in which I'm like oh well
there's the guy and this this is after
like no no kidding like probably 5 500
auditions
um of different actors we just went so
wide
um probably 30 people actually screen
testing I mean most movies maybe you
have two people like for mantis we had
like five people screening tests but
it's not many people screen testing a
lot of people screen testing and then
Chris came in and I just knew
immediately that he was the guy that he
took this role into another place with
where he was and this is when he was
pretty you know much chubbier than he is
it wasn't the the cut Chris Pratt that
you know about he was very chubby at
that time and it's been remarkable to
see his trajectory from the first movie
to this one because he's just full-on
movie star now yeah yeah I mean he's he
fills that role very well like you know
a few a few movie stars do who are just
such quality people I think you guys can
all agree like oh yeah the greatest guy
that is so incredible to work with and
so kind and so hilarious and just like
always in a good mood it's so easy to
work with him and what his heart is like
to not laugh during the scene so we're
gonna have to butt your tongue oh no I'm
not gonna laugh well Palm I'm glad that
you say that because I feel like
everyone is so excited to see the
dynamic between mantis and Peter Quill
in this movie after having learned from
the holiday special that their brother
and sister I love that because she
already had and shared that energy with
Drax yeah and can I just say upon that
no one can balance comedy and heart in
the way you do it truly is such a gift
and what I love about mantis is that she
can literally sense what people are
feeling through just touching them I
mean if you could bottle that up and
sell it to like single people in La
you'd make a million yeah
like your power ever so I wanted to ask
you I don't want to know what single
people in L.A so Palm I wanted to know
what is that like for you to step into
personally because what I think is
really cool is you actually get to touch
your cast mates it's not a superpower
that's done from a distance and I think
that that's really rare and special so I
wanted to know what that was like for
you and how it relates to Drax and Peter
in the third movie
uh no but first of all it was really I
mean it was kind of crazy to have to
hold on to this secret for such a long
time that we're like um brother and
sister right because you told me when
you cast me for the role it was like
okay okay I'm not gonna tell anyone
who's like oh my God I'm such a big
secret
so now we finally we can like openly
talk about it that's pretty amazing and
um and thank you for telling that I can
like bring like comedy and like um like
drama at the same time but it's also the
writing is so amazing too it helps no
but it's true that the the bond that you
have like between
um the characters now between mantis and
and Peter is is really strong and I
relate to that too because you know of
like family stuff with my own brother
and it was like beautiful and cathartic
to be um to be able to play that on
screen as well you know all the amazing
Dynamics we're going to see in this
movie like between Gamora and Peter and
between mantis and Peter I mean sibling
relationships to me are so sacred which
is why Sean it has truly been remarkable
to see what you and your brother have
built together I mean you guys have done
so many movies together and your work on
this franchise in particular is my
favorite and that's coming from someone
that almost dressed up as weasel for
Halloween
it truly and equally it has been so
beautiful to watch crackling grow from
having a couple lines in the first movie
to now being a full-on guardian in this
one but I don't know if everyone
watching knows that you pull double duty
and that you're also the onset rocket
and since volume three seems as though
it's going to really revolve around
rocket I wanted to know how did that
translate to your performance and did
you do any work for baby rocket
um
[Laughter]
yes I did to uh do some some work as as
baby rocket and
um you know the whole the whole
experience of the way I think of it is
that I'm a I'm a connector there's a
there's a whole team of people that go
into making rocket
um from James to Bradley Cooper to the
VFX team to everybody and I feel like my
job is primarily to help connect connect
the character to the other actors to
connect
to connect to James to connect the story
to Bradley when he's voicing the
character and to connect all the pieces
to the the VFX team as best I can
um and I I really look at Rocket as as
as being more even though I'm playing
the character I see a lot of James in in
rocket and I think of him as being sort
of um the essence of of of the soul of
of the Guardians in some way it's been a
heck of a ride playing the character I
don't I I it's not something I ever
would have thought that I that I would
have done in my career but um but it's
really been uh been an awesome
experience and very very joyful and
moving you know it's it's it's been a
moving process it's it is great I mean I
got to say that Sean it's it really
needs to get more credit for his
performances rocket because now I'm
really glad that craglin has become such
a primary character and it's really cool
to see
and people you're getting noticed for
that but at the same time like and
you'll see in this movie especially
there's a lot of scenes we shot in which
it is all about you know Rockets acting
and those eye movements everything that
he does it's all tracked off of Sean's
performance that is his performance you
know in in the movie
um and being able to for people to to
know that and to see that is important
it is an amalgamation of Sean and
Bradley and you know the visual effects
artist really in creating a character
but I don't I think it's unfair to un
you know undervalue Sean's performance
because we use it all throughout the
whole movie in terms of what Rockets
acting is and not just his voice and for
me it was invaluable
um our interaction together you know
that the fact that I didn't have to just
use a stuffed animal or whatever it was
very specific to acting to Sean and
there was you know there was a great day
without giving anything anything away
the one of the emotional peaks in the
many peaks in this movie that involved
his character and stuff and we were
trying to figure out the scene we would
done a few takes and then James said
come over come here come see the monitor
from the day before Sean had done motion
capture for it and all that so I went
back and I watched the scene and watched
what he did and right from what he did I
knew exactly how I had to go back and
play the thing you remember the scene
we're talking about because of he put
such emotional right down to the sounds
he was making that I was like oh that's
my way in so that sort of help is is
invaluable yeah and Sean it's such a
unique talent which is why I wanted to
ask you about it and he said it was
moving and I wonder if it's because your
brother really sees himself in rocket
and is someone who grew up with a
raccoon figurine collection and you've
always said that you felt so connected
to Rocket and that you wanted to come
back to finish his story he is the
secret protagonist why do you feel so
connected to raqqa and what do we we
going to find out about Rocket's origin
story in volume 3. I think we'll find
out who rocket really is I think we'll
find out where he's from how he came to
be the way he is and even saying that
makes me incredibly sad
um why because it's a very sad story and
a Rocket's backstory is very sad
um and I think that he's a a guy who was
a little innocent animal that was taken
out of his element and turned into
something that he was never meant to be
and was damaged
a lot by his experiences as a young kid
and his time has gone on he's be he's
he's he's reacted to that by coming
becoming a tough guy by becoming the
little snarly raccoon that we know from
the beginning of Guardians one who is
tough and mean and feisty and cruel even
and
um and all in all of that is a protect
action against who he really is which is
a scared little raccoon baby a
raccoon-like creature and so I think
that going through that Journey that's
the reason that I wanted to finish this
movie is to tell that story I thought it
was important for people to hear it it
was important for people to see it
um you know emotionally and spiritually
for the whole Guardians Trilogy it was
always at the center of what was
happening in all of the different
characters you know arcs are incredibly
important but they're all linked
together by Rockets story and um and I'm
really excited for people to see that I
I love how much you love animals and you
chose to tell this story through an
animal how does I'm thinking of how that
affects group who's you know we always
kind of pair Rocket and Groot together
um what version of GERD are we going to
see in this room because I'm picturing
like a teenage group that listens to
like Blink 182 and Fall Out Boy no he's
a little bit he's a little bit more than
that he's we'll see that this group so
you know OG Groot who died in volume one
gave birth to baby Groot who grew up
into like Surly teen Groot and is now um
who we call small Groot or young adult
group is very raring to go he's just got
that great College attitude of a guy
who's ready to go he's you know the guy
who's just in the end of college that's
ready to go out and conquer the world
believes in everything but he also you
know unlike you know original Groot who
was sort of unsocialized he was he has a
whole backstory in my head which I've
never even told but like he's was much
more of an aunt treated like an animal
for much of his life this group was was
treated as part of a family and he has a
bunch of fathers and mothers that have
raised him and in a lot of ways you know
group you know rocket is one of those
fathers but uh Peter Quill is also his
father and so those those relationships
are very important but also he's not
stupid he's a smart guy he's he's the
main pilot of the Bowie he's a he's a
really
um he's very competent you know he's a
smart guy with the limited vocabulary
but I'd love to move on to someone who
probably has an extensive vocabulary
here in these chairs and that's the high
evolutionary chikuti I am so excited
you're here you were just so brilliant I
mean you went to Yale now you're playing
a guy called the high evolutionary it's
no taser face but it's a pretty dope
name uh you know I I've heard you
describe him as a mad scientist and like
Shakespearean characters like Richard
III and King Lear which you were
fantastic in by the way how is he like
those Shakespearean characters and how
is he also alike or May maybe not alike
to other Marvel villains like Thanos and
Kang I think what makes this role and I
if I I really couldn't have landed on it
or been asked to be part of a role that
fits
my background better in the sense of who
this guy is because there is a lot of
Shakespeare in him
um I think Richard III certainly layers
suddenly the latter part of the film
you'll see that descent to where he gets
to towards the latter part and like I
said to James very much Henry IV Henry
IV when in Henry IV he in the latter
part of it he can't sleep because he has
the weight of England on his shoulders
and he has this beautiful speech in
which he says how many thousands of my
poorest subjects are at this moment
asleep or sleep wise thou forsaking me
what how have I wronged you that thou no
more will weigh my eyelids down
something like that I'm paraphrasing I
mean you know what I mean that's
incredible and I said to James I said I
I remember saying to him I was like oh
yeah he's Henry IV and I feel that was a
big part of the character for me because
I was like if I take into this guy's
character that he doesn't sleep
because of his drive to create the
perfect world that's a great Baseline to
start off with with the character so
there was that and then of course Dr
Moreau like mad scientists I think of
that movie Boys from Brazil I think it
was called with you know those
experiments I was like and on top of
that there's the bond villain in it the
charm the whatever and on top of that
it's a Marvel movie because at the end
of the day if you're doing a Marvel
villain there's certain prerequisites
you have to have you can't go all method
on it or you can't go all
you know seriously you have to have that
fact that it comes from
the most important of Pop Culture so you
have little things you have to you know
Grant a grandness to a grandiosity of
fun with it Embrace so it was all those
things in one but it was really
wonderful to have a character that had
the space to do that and one of the
first things James said to me was like
I've written this character
I don't know if Marvel knew exactly who
this character is I have it in my head
and I need you to ground it and that's
the perfect remit any actor wants in
that there's something very
carefully created but it's still
slightly ephemeral it still needs to be
brought down to earth and that's where
the acting instincts come by and you
combine and it was just a joy playing
with them because there were days I came
in and I gave him exactly what I know he
had in his mind the days when I didn't
give him what he had in his mind and we
would have to find it and the days when
I gave him something completely
different from what he had in his mind
and the director he is was like okay
let's explore that and then I would go
home bouncing like a kid going I know
there was a scene we had in our head but
what we found was whatever even cooler
and you have to ultimately like Palm
said
you have to have the material to do that
with ultimately if that character wasn't
there I couldn't have had the fun yeah I
had with it you know you speak of
material I remember in the 1972 Marvel
Premiere the power of warlock uh High
evolutionary does this like Buzz
Lightyear to Star Command thing where
he's like recording himself on
electronic journals so I was like
wondering if he had a comedic aspect to
him but in that comic too he also sort
of recruits Adam Warlock which people
are so excited for what relationship
does he have with Adam in this movie and
and what challenges Adam pose to the
Guardians Adam and high evolutionary
have a very uh um tight relationship
that's tighter than it is in the comics
um the high evolutionaries relationship
to The Sovereign the race from which uh
Adam was born is very tight relationship
Adam is beholden to eye evolutionary and
he is uh very eager to please him and
that's where we start the show basically
well I can tell you I feel like fans are
going to free because at the end of
Volume 2 in that post-credits scene when
Aisha says Adam everyone just like
freaked out so I'm so excited for that
and and post-credit scenes are such a
staple of the MCU and the Marvel
Cinematic Universe but you my friend are
now the new co-ceo of DC Studios and I
feel like sometimes there's this rivalry
between Marvel and DC fandoms but when
you look at creatives like yourself and
Kevin feige you can actually see that
there's a lot of love there between both
universes
um so because there's crossover between
DC and Marvel and the comics do you see
a day where we see these two universes
Collide on the big screen
I think there's always the possibility
of that you know I think that would be a
fun thing for fans to see but but I do
think that it's really about just
grounding the the Marvel and DC
universes right now and trying to you
know make them each as strong as
possible I think that the you know the
crossover that I like is that Kevin and
I are very close friends so we talk all
the time
um I think that you know the idea of a
rivalry between Marvel and DC of course
there's always going to be some rivalry
but what's really important to me is
that we embolden the movie going
experience and the theater going
experience is something that survives on
big spectacle movies today so if we are
going to really allow it to thrive that
means we want good movies to be made and
that's going to happen with Marvel
movies and DC and contrary to popular
belief a dollar for Marvel is not a
dollar dollar less for DC quite the
opposite you make good Marvel movies it
brings people to theaters they go see
more DC good DC movies you make good DC
movies brings them to the theater people
go see good Marvel movies so it's about
keeping that tradition alive and in that
way there is a crossover and there is
already you know we we work together
with you know with you know Warner
Brothers DC Disney all the different
Studios to uh you know try to keep that
being something that people are able to
enjoy
well thank you so much for this lovely
spectacle
um of volume three and really this
Trilogy in general I know that so much
of these movies have been made with the
same people in front of the screen
behind the screen Giuliana makovsky
who's done a costume Lars P who's been
first aid to now co-producer it really
is so beautiful like the art that you
guys have put into this for us in the
last decade so I just wanted to thank
you